The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
So where are we
in our grand list of our
five types of problems?
We've done weak acid in
water, weak base in water,
salt, and buffer.
We only have two left.
And that's what
we're going to talk
about right now-- strong
acids and strong bases.
And we're going to talk about
them in terms of acid base
titrations.
So switching to
today's handout, so
titrations-- how
many of you have done
a titration in a laboratory?
OK, a lot of people.
If you haven't, I have to say,
you're not missing anything.
It is really--
it's like watching
paint dry for most of the
time during the titration.
So here in an acid
base type titration,
you have the addition
of, say, a base
of known concentration to an
acid of unknown concentration.
And you can use
this by figuring out
what volume you need to
reach the equivalence point.
You can figure out
the concentration
of that acid or base.
If you know the concentration
of two things you,
can often use it
to figure out a Ka
or calculate a molecular weight.
But that's the purpose
of the titration.
So let's look at the shape
of these titration curves.
So here we have a strong
acid with a strong base.
So we start out.
All we have at point
0 is the strong acid.
So we should have
a very low pH here.
And then it should
change slowly.
Then it changes very rapidly
and then changes slowly again.
So what is this point S?
So that point S has
many, many names, which
are all equivalent.
It's called the
equivalence point,
and we had the clicker
question in the beginning
was mentioning that.
The S here really stands for
the stoichiometric point.
Both of these are
the same thing.
And it's the theoretical
volume and which
that base that you've added,
the number of moles of that base
is equal to the number
of moles of acid you had.
So it's the point of which the
moles are equal to each other.
And so that stoichiometric
1-to-1, or equivalence.
The moles are equivalent.
So all these names are the same.
They all mean the same thing.
Don't get tricked if problem
say one thing or the other.
You also might hear end point.
That's often the result of
the experiment that you do,
where you figure out
what volume you needed
to add to have a color change.
So the way these work
usually is you have this,
and you go drip, drip, drip,
and you look for a color change.
And at that point
of the color change,
the first little hint
of the color change
is where you want to stop
and measure the volume.
But often you get
very frustrated,
and you go from totally
clear, you're very, very slow,
and you're right in here.
And then you can't
stand it anymore.
You jump right up
here, and you have
to do it over and over again.
But it should be that
the end point should
equal the equivalence point.
So if you're good at
these kinds of problems,
you might be able to do a
quick and dirty, estimate what
the value is, and then figure
out exactly how much you can
add before you have to go
slow, i.e. you can cheat,
which I highly recommend in
doing these kinds of laboratory
exercises.
So knowing how to do
the math is really
valuable of these problems.
So we add a strong
acid and a strong base.
Here's the same curve
for a strong base
with a strong acid, where
we're adding the strong acid
into the strong base.
Again, now we're going to start
in the beginning at point 0
before we've added any acid.
We have a basic pH.
It goes slow, goes
fast through point
S, the equivalence point
or stoichiometric point,
and then goes slow again.
So how do you know?
And the TSs are going
to come down and do
a little demo for you
now about pH indicators.
How do you know?
And for those of you who have
done these experiments in lab,
again, you have
this color change.
And usually you're clear.
You go a little bit more.
You have a little bit
more, and you go to this.
But as I was saying,
what happens most of time
is you go from this clear, all
the way to the really dark,
and you have to start all
over again because you
missed the end point.
So these pH indicators
are able to tell you
that there's this change in pH.
So the TAs are going to show
you, using a pH-- come on in.
Set up.
I'm just talking
while you set up.
Over there-- you can use the
document camera if you need it.
So our demo TAs have created a
natural dye from red cabbage.
And this dye, when it's in
acid, has a slightly different
structure then in base, which
causes it to have these two
different colors.
So we can tell which
things are acidic
and which things are basic by
the color of the indicator.
And I'm just going to hand
over a mic if it's on.
TEACHING ASSISTANT: Is it on?
Yes?
OK, great.
So we've got our solutions here.
This is lemon juice.
Did I put water in here?
Right?
Yeah, water, vinegar, I think.
Maybe it vinegar--
this is vinegar.
Don't do that.
Don't do that in lab.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: In
the lab you should always
label your containers.
TEACHING ASSISTANT: Yes, indeed.
So we've got lemon juice,
water, vinegar, and ammonia.
Did you add some
water into that?
Can you?
So we're going to add a
little bit of the indicator.
The indicator came
from red cabbage.
So the dye in the
red cabbage, it
is a molecule that
can be protonated.
And when the molecule
gets protonated,
basically it's double
bonds start moving around.
And when you do that, it
absorbs light differently.
So what we're going to see
when we pour into there
is that you'll see this,
which is the acid forms
a nice pinkish color.
This was the water.
And when you pour it into the
water, nothing really happens.
And you can kind of understand
that because the indicator
itself is a
water-based solution.
So it's going to be purple.
This was the vinegar.
And as we did last time,
the vinegar is acidic.
And this was the ammonia.
And I'm going to add
little bit of water.
Can you add a little bit
of water into this one?
You added it?
OK, great.
And then we're going to kind
of do a little excursion here.
So what this, this
is a piece of-- oh,
it's cold-- a piece of dry
ice, which is just solid CO2.
And what I'm going to do is I'm
going to drop it into there.
So this is kind of a bit of a--
CATHERINE DRENNAN: [INAUDIBLE]?
TEACHING ASSISTANT:
Yeah, put it over here.
So this is an interesting demo
because-- oh, that's not useful
at all.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yeah,
actually we can change--
AUDIENCE: Can we change that?
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Maybe.
TEACHING ASSISTANT:
Oh, maybe not.
Oh, well, it's fine.
Oh, man.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
I think we can do that.
But this is beyond my
ability [INAUDIBLE].
TEACHING ASSISTANT: Well,
what I was talking about
was basically when you drop the
CO2 into this mixture, what's
happening is that the
CO2 actually decomposes,
and it forms something
called carbonic acid.
Good idea.
Carbonic acid is an
acid, so it will actually
change the pH of the
solution as we're talking.
And what this is relevant for
is really for global warming.
So we know about companies when
they make-- I mean, it's true.
When we have companies
and they make
lots of kinds of
chemical compounds,
they'll release CO2
into the atmosphere.
And when the CO2 gets
released-- is it working or no?
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Upside down!
That's even cooler.
TEACHING ASSISTANT:
Oh, look at that.
So when the CO2 gets
released into the atmosphere,
basically, by Le
Chatelier's principle,
you add all this CO2.
It will force the reaction to
start making carbonic acid.
And that will react
with the water vapor
and start making the water
in the air very acidic.
Wow, that's not useful at all.
And the color's not
really changing.
But it was supposed to.
(LAUGHING)
CATHERINE DRENNAN: We have time.
We can keep an eye on it.
TEACHING ASSISTANT: I think we
may have added too much base.
But we can keep an eye on it
and watch the color change
while it's upside down,
which is really useful.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yes,
because that's really cool.
TEACHING ASSISTANT: But
anyway, yeah, that's
how the indicator works.
And, yeah, that's that, I guess.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: OK, great.
[APPLAUSE]
CATHERINE DRENNAN: So
we can leave this here.
I'll switch the document
the camera back.
And you might add a little more.
It's very concentrated still.
See if we can get a little bit
more without too much overflow.
I think it's changing
a little bit actually.
Yeah.
Well, we'll keep an eye on it.
So let's go through and
calculate some points
on a strong acid and base curve.
So we can check off those two
final types of pH problems.
So here, when we're calculating
strong acid and strong bases,
say we have a strong base
that's 2.5 molar, NaOH
being traded with a strong
acid, HCl at 0.34 molar.
So first, we want
to calculate the pH
before the equivalence
point, when we've just added,
say, 5 mLs of our strong
acid to the solution which
was 25 mLs of our strong base.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is calculate how many
moles of base that is.
So how many did we have in here?
And since this base
is strong, the number
of moles of sodium
hydroxide added
equals the amount
of hydroxide formed.
That's the definition
of a strong base.
And it is hydroxide, so pretty
much that's how much you get.
So all we have to do is
know how to calculate
the number of moles.
And that is the
volume that we had,
and we're converting that to
liters times our concentration.
And so that gives us 6.25
times 10 to the minus 3 moles.
So we know how many
moles of OH we have.
Now we need to figure out
how many moles of acid
we added when we added 5
milliliters of the acid.
So it's a strong acid.
So the moles of acid
added equal the number
of moles of our hydronium ions
that are formed-- definition
of strong acid.
And so we had 5 milliliters.
We convert to liters
times our concentration.
That gives us 1.7 times
10 to the minus 3 moles.
So now we need to
figure out what
the new amount of hydroxide is.
So we're going to convert.
Some of our hydroxide will
react with the amount of acid
added because the
stoichiometry is one-to-one,
you're going to react equal
numbers of OH with H3O-plus.
So we had 6.25 times 10
to the minus 3 moles.
We've added this number
of moles of acid.
So that many moles are going
to be formed into salt.
And we're left with this
minus this, or 4.55 times
10 to the minus 3
moles of OH-minus left.
So at this point, this is a
strong base and water problem.
All we have as hydroxide
ions left in our solution.
We've converted all
the acid that we
added into salt because
it reacted with the base.
And so this is a
strong base now.
So for strong base, all we have
to do is calculate the molarity
and then calculate pOH and pH.
So for molarity,
We have the number
of moles left, 4.55 times 10 to
the minus 3, in our new volume.
And this is the part
where people forget.
We had 25 mLs.
We added five more.
So our new volume is 30 mLs.
And so we have a
new concentration.
And then from that,
we calculate pH.
First we do pOh, plugging in
our hydroxide ion concentration.
and then calculate
pH, using the fact
that at room temperature--
and all these problems
are room temperature-- that
would be 14 minus the pOH
is the pH.
And we have a point somewhere
around here, point B,
on our titration curve after
we've add 5 mLs of strong acid.
Our pH is still pretty
basic-- 13.18 left.
So strong base in water
problem-- all you have to do
is calculate the concentration
of OH-minus, then the pOH,
and then the pH.
So you don't have to have any of
these minus and pluses in terms
of setting up our tables
and using Ka's and Kb's
For a weak base
in water problem,
it's a concentration of
hydroxide ion-- pOH pH.
So let's move on now
and think about what
volume we would need to get
to the stoichiometric point.
So you're often
asked to calculate
the volume of the
strong acid needed
to get to the stoichiometric
or the equivalence point.
And to do this,
you need to think
about how many moles
of OH you have,
because at the
equivalence point,
you have equal numbers
of moles of acid.
So we had 6.25 times 10 to the
minus 3 moles of OH originally.
And at the equivalence point,
then, how many moles of acid
do we need to add?
We have to add that exact
same number, by definition.
So the equivalence point,
it's the stoichiometric point.
So if you know how many
moles of the base you had,
that's going to be equal to the
moles of acid you need to add.
So now we want to figure out
the volume that that's needed.
We know the number of
moles that we need,
and we know the
concentration, so now we just
have to calculate the volume.
So we have the moles.
We use the concentration
of the acid
to figure out the volume
that has to be added.
And what would be
the pH at this point?
It would be 7.
So this is a really fast
question to ask on an exam,
because all you
have to do is say,
if it was a strong
base in a strong acid,
they're going to form a neutral
salt in water, so the pH is 7.
And that's it.
No calculations needed.
You can answer that question
very quickly-- so strong acid,
strong base, at the equivalence
point, equal number of moles.
You're going to get a
salt that's neutral.
In the salt here, we have HCl
and NaOH is just NaCl, salt.
So remember, at the
equivalence point, strong acid,
strong base, the pH
is going to be 7.
So now let's go down here
and try point D so just
beyond the equivalence point.
So here we want to calculate
the pH after 1 mL of strong acid
has been added after you have
reached the equivalence point.
So you went 1 mL too
far in your titration,
and this is a strong
acid in water problem,
so our last type
of problem here.
So first what you
want to do is figure
out how many moles of this acid
were added due to this 1 mL
extra.
And again, it's a strong
acid, so the amount of acid
added is going to be
equal to the hydronium ion
concentrations formed--
definition of strong acid.
So we had a concentration
of 0.34 of our strong acid.
We added 1 mL extra,
so we have 3.4 times 10
to the minus 4
moles of H3O-plus.
Now we need to calculate
the molarity of that,
and that's a clicker question.
So the trick here is
just to think about what
is the volume at this point.
And if we look
over here-- do you
want to just-- you can it out.
We're trying a couple
of different variations
of the experiment over here.
But we'll just see if
we can get it over time.
Maybe we'll come back
to that at the end.
We'll just leave it
there and say, OK.
Or did you want
to say something?
Why don't you talk about
it briefly, and then we'll
look at the--
TEACHING ASSISTANT: We
did the experiment again
with a less concentrated
solution, added several pieces
of dry ice.
And as you can see,
the color-- yeah,
we can put it on the camera.
I don't know if we can.
It's fine.
But the color's
changing very slowly,
which is a lot slower than
we expected it to change.
But you dilute
the concentration,
and this is turning blue.
And it will eventually
turn into a yellowish-pink,
which is when it will
officially become an acid.
So we'll just leave that there.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
We'll keep an eye on it
for the next few minutes.
So the trick here was to
figure out the volume.
So you had 25 mLs to begin with.
You needed 18.4 to get
to the stoichiometric
or the equivalence point.
Then you added one more
past the equivalence point.
And if you remembered to add
those three volumes together,
then you will get the
right concentration.
And when you get the
right concentration,
the rest of the
problem is very easy.
And I'll just mention also,
significant figures here.
We have three here because
we had three there.
And so then you just
take the pH of this.
This is the hydronium
ion concentration.
And that will give your answer.
And it'll be pH 2.116 with all
of those significant figures,
which you can never
measure that accurately.
But nonetheless, that's what
the rules would tell us.
So a strong acid
in water problem
is you just calculate
the hydronium ion
concentration and then pH.
So this is a pretty simple part.
So if we go back
now to our diagram,
we've measured a
couple of parts.
We measured point B. And
so we had a pH of 13.18.
This was like a strong
base in water problem.
At a point S, we
calculated that we
needed 18.4 mLs of strong
acid, and our pH is 7.
And so the trick to
doing this problem
was just to remember that
the moles of strong acid
equal the moles of strong
base at this point.
And then from point D, 1 mL past
the equivalence point, the pH
was 2.116, and this is like a
strong acid in water problem.
And notice how dramatic it is.
Up here you're at pH 7.
You add 1 mL too much, and
you're already at pH 2.
So this is a very rapid change.
This is why a lot of these
experiments are so frustrating.
That you add a
little bit too much,
and you're just
way, way, way beyond
the stoichiometric point.
So in one titration
curve here, we
have three types of problems.
But as we get into weak acid in
weak base, which we'll do now,
you'll see that a
titration curve is actually
all five types of problems.
So this is why one wants to
start problems set 7 early.
So we've done all of these now.
And now we can apply all
of these types of problems
while doing weak acid
strong base part.
And we'll just start this,
and we'll continue it later.
But let's go through
the curves now.
So this is in your handout.
This is the curve for the
weak acid in strong base.
And I just want to remind you
what we just talked about,
which is strong
acid in strong base.
So for weak acid in
strong base, the curves
look quite a bit different.
So here we start at a higher
pH, because it's a weak acid.
Here's lower.
It's a strong acid.
Then we go up.
The pH levels off.
And this is called
the buffering region.
There's no such buffering region
with a strong acid strong base,
because strong acids and strong
bases don't form good buffers.
But weak acids and strong bases
can generate good buffering
region because a strong base can
convert some of the weak acid
to its conjugate weak
base, and that creates
a buffer in this region.
Then the pH starts
to change again.
It's constant in the buffering
region, starts to change again.
You get to the
equivalence point.
The definition of
equivalence points
are the same-- equal
number of moles of acids
and base at the
equivalence point.
But now the equivalence
point is not at pH 7 anymore.
It's greater than pH 7 because
we've converted our weak acid
to its conjugate base.
So up here we have
conjugate base,
which makes it more basic.
And so the pH is greater than 7.
And then the curve
goes up again.
We also have something that's
special for a weak with strong
titration that doesn't
exist with strong -strong,
and that's called the
half-equivalence point.
The half-equivalence
point is the point
where half the volume and
half the number of moles
needed to reach the equivalence
point have been added.
So that's the
half-equivalence point.
It's half of the
equivalence point.
So let's just look at these--
a couple of different points
here.
And look at this figure here,
and we'll end with this.
And I'm just going to
have my TAs come down
and just help me
with this last part.
So let's see if we
can get two more.
We already have
someone with a hat.
You have a hat.
We have two more TAs.
So these are all
weak acids over here.
So we have just our weak acids,
and we have four of them.
Other TAs who want to
come down, can help out.
This is volume equals 0.
So this is like a weak
acid in water problem.
So now let's bring our moles
of strong base over here.
So now, Amanda, you're a
strong base, so you're 1.
So you're going to react just
with one of these weak acids
deprotonate it and
form a conjugate base.
There we go.
And then you can go off and
form your salt and water.
So now we have a
buffer situation.
And we have a buffer
situation when
we have some conjugate acid
and some conjugate base.
We have a special type
of category of buffer
at the half-equivalence
point, where
you have half the conjugate
S and half the conjugate A.
So another mole of strong
base comes in and deprotonates
one of our acid.
So why don't you be-- yeah,
and you go off and form a salt.
And so then we have half
the weak acid and half
the conjugate base.
Now, as we go on, we're going
to reach the equivalence point.
And now we've added an
amount of strong base
that will fully
deprotonate our weak acid.
So why don't we have two
more strong bases come along
and deprotonate.
And so now we have
only weak bases left.
There are just weak
bases left because we
added equal numbers of
moles of our strong base
as we had weak acid.
So now we have conjugate base.
So this is like a weak
base in water problem.
And then at the end, if
we add more strong base,
and a strong base comes
over, there's nothing to do.
He's just strong
base in solution.
And so this is a strong
base in water problem.
So the point is one
titration problem
is really five different
types of acid base problems.
So start problem set 7 early.
See you on Wednesday.
Let's just take 10 more seconds.
I have a feeling that
more people understand
how to do this, but
it's just a matter
of thinking about
the sign of things.
So the trick here-- you
have a pH of 4, pKa of 4.19.
And so, obviously,
it's the difference.
But you have to
think about if you
want the ratio to be A minus
2 A, which expression you're
going to use here to
give you the correct one.
So just pay attention
to your sign.
Always show all your
work on an exam.
So today, we're going
to finish the lecture
notes from last
time on titrations,
continue with titrations.
And toward the end
of the class, we're
going to start the next unit,
which is oxidation reduction.
So we want to take
out lecture note
23, top of page 4,
where we had this curve.
So as we were
finishing last time,
we saw the curve for a
titration of a weak acid
with a strong base.
And this is the
curve for a weak base
that's being titrated
traded with a strong acid.
And drawing curves on an exams--
that's one of my favorite exam
questions So make sure
you know how to draw
these types of titrations.
So things that you should pay
attention to in drawing them,
if it is a weak base
that's being titrated
with a strong acid,
you would expect
that before you've added
any acid, that you're
going to have a basic pH.
So at point 0 here, you
would expect a basic pH.
So then the pH starts
decreasing as you're
titrating in the strong acid.
And you go into this
region of constant pH,
where that's the
buffering region.
So the pH is
changing very little.
It plateaus.
It's flat.
So when you're drawing
a region like this,
make sure that in the curve
it looks kind of flat,
because the idea of
a buffering region
is that the pH
isn't changing much.
Here you have the conjugate
acid and the conjugate base,
so it's a buffer-like problem.
Then when you get out of
that buffering region,
the pH drops rapidly,
which is often
one of the funs in doing
these titrations in lab.
Nothing's changing.
And all of a sudden,
you're down here.
So at the equivalence
point here,
the equivalence point is
going to be below pH 7
because at this point, you have
added the same number of moles
of acid as the weak base.
So you've converted
all of the weak base
to its conjugate acid.
So the pH is below 7, and
then it drops off rapidly.
So again, in these
titration problems,
there are really five different
types of problems within them.
When you have the
volume of zero,
it's a weak base
in water problem.
In this buffering region
here, it's a buffer problem.
And there's a special
kind of buffer problem
at the half-equivalence
point, where
the number of moles
of the conjugate acid
formed equal the number
of moles of baes.
And then we get to
the equivalence point,
and now we've converted
all the weak base
to its conjugate acid.
So this is just a weak
acid in water problem.
And then down here, it's a
strong acid in water problem.
So again, the trick
in doing these
is to recognize where
you are in the curve
and figure out what
type of problem it is.
Once you figure out what
type of problem it is,
it's usually not
so bad to solve it
because you can all figure
out how to solve these five
types of problems.
It's recognizing what type of
problem it is at various times
during the titration.
and in some of the
problem set problems,
you'll have all of the
various points to do.
But in an exam,
you're going to just
be thrown into the
middle of a titration
and have to think about where
it is in the midst of titration
what type of problem is it.
So now we're going to go
through and do an example, work
point by point for a titration.
And the titration
we're going to do
is a weak acid in a strong base.
So that's the curve here.
So we start at low
pH and then go up.
So the particular problem
we're going to work--
and we're going to
work all these points.
And then we're going
to have a bonus point
E at the end-- is formic acid.
And we have 25 mLs of
0.1 molar formic acid.
And we're titrating
with a strong base,
sodium hydroxide, 0.15 molar.
And you're often going to
be given the Ka of the acid.
So the first point,
point A, is volume zero.
You haven't added any
of your strong base yet.
So you can write the expression
for what's going on there.
You have your acid
plus water going
to hydronium ion
concentration, and you're
forming the conjugate
base of that weak acid.
So this is, again,
a weak acid problem.
So you know how to do
weak acid problems.
So titrations are
just a collection
of problems we've already
talked about how to do.
So just very briefly, we'll
go through this pretty fast
at this point.
So we have our
weak acid in water.
We had 0.1 molar, and
we had none of the other
to begin with.
So we're at zero volume here.
So as the equilibrium is
reached, we have 0.10 minus x,
x, and x.
So because this is a weak
acid in water problem,
we can use Ka to solve the
problem, which is our acid
ionization constant.
It's 1.77 times 10 to the minus
4 for this particular one.
We can set this up it's products
over reactants at equilibrium.
So x squared over 0.10 minus x.
Again, water doesn't fit in.
That's our solvent, so
it's not in our expression.
We can solve this
with the quadratic,
or we can assume
that x is small,
which, again, is a pretty
good assumption usually
for a weak acid problem.
And by assuming x is small, that
means this minus x drops out.
So we're saying x is small
compared to the concentration
that we started with.
And then we can solve for x.
If we do that here, we get
0.00421, and that we can check,
and we find that it is 4.2%
of 0.1, so that's under 5%.
So that assumption is OK.
Again, I'm using the 5% rule.
And then we can solve this.
x is our hydronium
ion concentration.
So we can plug that
in and get an answer.
But now I want you to tell me
how many sig figs this has.
And to do that, you
have to figure out
how many sig figs were
actually in this number here.
So you have to go back
and look at the problem
and figure out the total
number of sig figs.
See how easy that was to fix?
So it is two,
because this had two,
and the concentration
was limiting here
to two significant figures.
So there were two
here, which means
there are two after
the decimal point here.
And I have to say I was
looking a problem set 7,
and some of those
problems are just
like if you love
significant figures,
they're a joy because you've
got adding and subtracting.
And then you had division,
and then you have logs.
It is the triple whammy
of sig fig love-- so two
after the decimal point.
So we have 0.1.
We have a pH that's acetic.
That's good because
at the beginning,
all we have is a weak acid.
So we have a pH of
2.38, so that's point A.
So now let's look at this region
here in the buffering region.
And again, the
buffering region is
when you have added
volumes of your acid
that are greater than zero but
less than the volume needed
to reach equilibrium.
And so in this
particular problem,
we're going to
calculate what happens
when 5 mLs of our
strong base are added.
So this is basically
point B here.
And because it's a
strong base, it's
going to react with all of
the same number of moles
of our weak acid.
It's much stronger than
the conjugate base.
So it's going to react pretty
much completely with this.
So we can write out that
the weak acid plus our base
are going to be converted
over to the conjugate base
of this weak acid.
So we can just
figure out the moles
and then subtract them to
understand how much is left
and how much is being formed.
So first, then, we
need to figure out
how many moles we had initially.
So for our acid, we had
25 mLs of 0.10 molar.
So we have 2.5 times 10
to the minus 3 moles.
For our hydroxide, our strong
base, we've added 5 mLs.
And it was a 0.15
molar solution.
So we 0.75 times 10
to the minus 3 moles.
So now there's going
to be this reaction.
So we want to think
about what happens
after you have the
reaction of the strong base
with the weak acid.
And so just to
emphasize this point,
say we have 8 moles
of our acid here
and we added just 1
mole of our strong base.
That will react, pull off,
deprotonate, and form water,
and form the conjugate base.
So net we had eight.
We added one of the strong base.
So we have seven left.
And we've formed one
of the conjugated base.
And so I'm just showing this
here because so often on exams,
I see people just
plug the initial moles
into the later part, and
they forget that there's
a reaction happening.
And so I was hoping
if I would show this,
I'm going to get people used
to thinking about, OK, I'm
adding strong base.
What's happening?
How much is being converted?
And if you're not
subtracting things,
there's a problem with the
way you're doing the problem.
So here, these are less
easy numbers to visualize.
2.5 times 10 to the
minus 3 moles, how much
we had of our weak acid.
We have added a strong base at
0.75 times 10 to the minus 3.
So we have 1.75 times 10 to the
minus 3 moles of our acid left.
So we subtract the amount that's
converted due to the addition
of the base.
And so why don't you
tell me how much, then,
we're going to have of our
conjugate base being formed.
So I kind of tried
to fool you there.
But 70% of you
were not having it.
So here, it's going to be equal
to the number of moles of a OH
that's added because that's how
much is going to be converted.
That's how much of
the conjugate acid
is converted to
the conjugate base.
Now, we have moles.
We need molarity if
we're going to use a Ka
to solve the problem, because
the expression for equilibrium
constant has
molarity, not moles.
So then in converting
to molarity,
the thing you have to
remember is the volume.
So we had 25 mLs to start
with, and now we've added 5.
So we need to make sure that
we have the correct number
of liters in our expressions.
So we can calculate 1.75
times 10 to the minus 3 moles
for our weak acid, volume
concentration of weak acid.
We have 0.75 times 10 to the
minus 3 of our conjugate base.
And then we have a
concentration there.
Now, there are two ways
to solve this problem.
And option one uses Ka.
It doesn't involve
Henderson-Hasselbalch.
Option two will involve
Henderson-Hasselbalch,
and it's OK to use this because
this is a buffer problem.
So option one now for
calculating point B--
so we can set up
this expression.
And always remember you're
talking about molarity here,
so don't put in your
moles in this expression.
Only put in molarity.
So that's why the
volume's really important.
So we can put in our
concentration 0.0583,
and it'll will be minus
x for equilibrium plus x
for our hydronioum ion
concentration and also
our concentration of the
conjugate base 0.0250 plus x.
So this is like a buffer
problem, using option one.
And so we can use Ka,
plug in our values.
Here we have our conjugate
base concentration
at equilibrium
times our hydronium
ion, x over the equilibrium
molarity of our weak base.
We can, again,
assume x is small,
which drops out the
plus x and the minus x.
We solve for x.
We get 4.13 times
10 to the minus 4.
We can check the assumption.
And sure enough, it's
much smaller, 1.7%,
0.7% of these two.
And you really only
need to check one.
The smaller one--
assumptions OK.
And we can calculate
then by putting
in x, which is hydronium
ion concentration,
into the equation pH equals
minus log of the hydronium ion
concentration
equals the pH 3.38.
We can also use
Henderson-Hasselbalch,
because it's a buffer problem.
It's allowed.
You were given the Ka.
You can calculate pKa minus the
log of Ka and put that number
in, put in the concentrations
that you determined.
So you still need to
subtract the moles.
You can skip that step.
But you can skip
the volume step.
Because when you use
Henderson-Hasselbalch,
the volume would cancel
out if you had moles
per volume moles per volume.
The volume's the same.
So you can skip the calculating
molarity step here--
that simplifies the
problem-- and solve.
And you should get
the exact same number,
or something was wrong.
Both of these should
work equally well-- 3.38.
But you'll often
be asked to check
the Henderson-Hasselbalch
assumption.
And remember there was
an assumption here,
because we solved the
Henderson-Hasselbalch
from an equation that use
Ka, the equilibrium constant.
So really this expression
is at equilibrium,
but we're plugging in values
that are not at equilibrium.
They're the initial
values that we're
putting into this equation.
So we still need to check,
and we're using the 5% rule.
So to check the
Henderson-Hasselbalch,
then, we have to back
calculate pH of 3.38
equals a hydronium ion
concentration of 4.2 times 10
to the minus 4.
And then you want to check that
that number is less than 5%
of the smaller number.
And we checked that assumption
when we looked at option A.
So it's still good for
option B. And we can
use the HendersonHasselbalch.
Now, if it was greater
than 5%, then you
can only use option one.
And you must use the
quadratic equation.
But this doesn't
happen very often
because a buffer is usually
not a very good buffer
if x is not small.
A buffer's a good boss for when
you have a weak conjugate acid
pair.
And when you have weak
conjugate acids and bases, then
usually x is small.
It doesn't ionized
much in water.
So most of the time
these assumptions hold.
But if you're asked to
check an assumption,
that's what you need to do.
So we have point B two ways,
and we got the same answer.
It's 3.38.
And that's point B, and we're
in the buffering region there.
What about point C?
Point C is the
half-equivalence point.
So let's think about
what the pH would be
at the half-equivalence point.
So at the
half-equivalence point,
by definition, you've
added half the number
of moles you need to reach
the equivalence point, or half
the volume of the strong
base that you need
to reach the equivalence point.
And at this point, the number
of moles of your weak acid
equal the number of moles
of your conjugate base.
So when that is true and we look
at the Henderson-Hasselbalch
expression, we see that
this term becomes 1,
and so therefore pH equals pKa.
So if you weren't given the pKa
and you were just given the Ka,
that's no problem because
you can calculate it--
minus log of Ka.
And so that's minus log of
1.77 times 10 to the minus 4
for this problem, which
gives us a pH about 3.75.
So if you were just given the
pKa, which is for this 3.75,
and it's really not
much more significant
than that, honestly.
And there actually not a lot
of significant figures when it
comes to measuring pH or pKa's.
If on a test it said,
the pKa of this is 3.75.
What is the pH at the
half-equivalence point?
You could write down
3.75 and nothing else.
You do not need to prove to
me that this expression here
is true at the
half-equivalence point.
It's just a way to ask
a question that tests
your knowledge of titrations.
So this is a good problem that
involves very little work,
so you should be extremely
excited if I'm asking you
about the pH at a
half-equivalence point,
because that's going to
be a real easy problem.
Don't spend a lot of time on it.
So we got point C,
3.75-- very close.
We're sort of in this
region where the pH
is changing not that much.
So that's the end
of that lecture.
But the beginning of the next
one starts where we left off.
As I said, acid base titration
problems take a long time.
They're in two
handouts, and we're just
going to continue now with
the next handout and point
S, the equivalence point.